الى السودان حيث تتواصل ردود الفعل على
تحديد سقف زمني للعمليه السياسيه حيث راى
رئيس مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان ان
المرحله التي تقبل عليها البلاد ستكون
مرضيه للجميع واكد البرهان ان القوات
المسلحه هي صمام الامان للبلاد مبديا
للحرص على الا تمس شعر منها بحسب وصفه
التدافع السياسي الحاصل هناك في الخرطوم
نحن تدافع سياسي ايجابي تدافع سياسي يهدف
الى مصلحه الوطن تدافع سياسي يهدف الى
بناء السودان نحن دايرين من المقبلين على
مرحله جديده نحن افتكر انه سيحصل انتقال
سيحصل تحول في قياده الدوله او في اداره
الدوله دايرين هذا التحول يكون مرضي للناس
مقبول للناس الناس متفقين عليهم
انتقال تنازع والله فيه تشذي والله فيه
تشرز والله في انحياز فئه نحن في الجيش
مع طرف طول الاخر نحن موقفنا موقف ثابت
موقف وطني ندعم الاستقرار
كما دعى البرهان جميع السياسيين
السودانيين الى توسيع افقهم وتقبل الاخرين
من اجل فتره انتقاليه سلسه تفضي الى تنظيم
الانتخابات وكذا ضروره ان تكون كل القوى
موجوده في العمليه السياسيه الجاريه حتى
لا تتعثر هذه العمليه
المسار الهجري الان دع منه دعمي كامل ومحل
تراجع منه لكن بنقول والله هذا المسار اذا
ما استصحب القوه الرئيسيه اذا ما استصحب
كل السودانيين سيتعسر قريبا ولن يستطيع ان
يمضي نحن بناكد انه والله هذه العمليه
السياسيه يجب ان تكون شامله فيها كل الناس
يعبر عن ارائهم كل الناس صوتهم موجود فيها
كل الناس صوتهم مسموع فيها اذا مشيت
مبتوره او مشت عرجاء ستتعسر وستسقط ولن
تستطيع ان تمضي الى الامام